they run marathons
can one of the views Hot Topics be too
hot oh my gosh that's a hard question
yeah Sarah Haynes might have found the
answer on Wednesday when the talk show
was forced to cut mics then to
Commercial and I love Reinventing and I
love it's magical I've always been
someone that feeds off other people's
energy
so what happened let's recap so
apparently there is a show coming which
I'm calling the old people's back well
that's one way to put it charity we
accept this Rose absolutely after 20
years the franchise calls its newest
love story The Golden Bachelor helping
one hopeless romantic find a partner to
share the sunset years of life
more relatable to see people that I
could look at and say you look at it
more complicated you look at it more
layered oh my gosh this is so cool to
watch first of all Viagra could be the
commercials Joy Behar with the jokes per
usual but it's a comment from Sarah that
leaves everyone in stitches
I know 60 year olds they run marathons
we'll be right back
so what did Sarah say that was not safe
for work that remains unclear and when
the show came back from commercial
Whoopi Goldberg the show's longtime
moderator keeps everyone in the dark
so um
just an institution I feel honored to be
at the table as fans of the daytime
staple know unexpected commercial breaks
are pretty common what you're doing no
I'm not sure we're not doing anything
how about this former FBI we'll be right
back
who wouldn't want to come back to that
round table while the mystery of What
Sarah Said goes unsolved for now viewers
might have a pretty good idea of what
she was getting at them
60 year olds they run marathons
we'll be right back
it's unreal it always is
foreign